[Música]
el expresidente estadounidense Donald
Trump advirtió que sería arrestado Este
martes y llamó a sus seguidores a
protestar el mandatario no precisó el
motivo de su presunto arresto pero sus
declaraciones se dan en medio de las
audiencias por el supuesto pago a una
actriz de películas para adultos
El Vaticano cerró su embajada en la
capital nicaragüense y su representante
tuvo que salir del país hacia Costa Rica
la medida se da luego de una escalada
verbal entre ambos estados agudizada por
la persecución del gobierno de Daniel
Ortega a la iglesia católica
un terremoto de magnitud 6,5 se registró
en Ecuador dejando al menos 14 personas
muertas según cifras del gobierno las
autoridades descartaron advertencia de
Tsunami y el gobierno se enfoca en la
atención de los damnificados
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Estados Unidos el expresidente Donald
Trump vuelve a estar en el centro de la
actualidad después de regresar a
Facebook y YouTube publicó en su red
social 3 que una filtración le informó
que será arrestado el martes al parecer
por los pagos con fondos de la campaña
de 2016 a la actriz stormy Daniels a
cambio de su silencio y animó a sus
seguidores a protestar contra la
detención y a recuperar la nación Según
dijo lluís Muñoz tiene más detalles
tormenta Trump el expresidente dijo en
su red social red social que podría ser
arrestado el martes un mensaje que
recordó al que precedió al asalto al
Capitolio ahora filtraciones ilegales de
una corrupta y altamente politizada
oficina del fiscal de Manhattan que ha
permitido que se establezcan nuevos
récords de crímenes violentos y cuyo
líder está financiado por George soros
indican que sin que se pueda aprobar
ningún Crimen y basándose en un viejo y
totalmente desacreditado por numerosos
otros Fiscales Cuento de hadas el
candidato republicano más importante y
el expresidente de los Estados Unidos de
América será arrestado el martes de la
próxima semana protestas recuperen
nuestra nación un gran Jurado de Nueva
York que Investiga los presuntos pagos
de Trump durante la campaña de 2016 para
silenciar a la actriz porno estormy
Daniels y a la modelo de Playboy Karen
por un total de 280 mil dólares pagos
registrados como gastos legales sería el
primer ex presidente en ser acusado de
un delito esto podría afectar carrera
presidencial
el Cardo que puede presentar El fiscal y
que parece que está a punto de presentar
es que Trump falsificó los registros
comerciales de la organización Trump lo
cual es criminal en Nueva York si
falsifica los registros comerciales de
una empresa comercial Entonces está
sujeto a una sanción de al menos seis
meses eso es un delito menor pero si lo
hace para ocultar otro delito Entonces
se convierte en un delito grave y eso
puede darte una sentencia de hasta 4
años que es un impacto mucho mayor
Trump también enfrenta investigaciones
criminales en Atlanta y Washington por
sus esfuerzos para revertir los
resultados en 2020 también se investigan
los documentos clasificados encontrados
en el domicilio del ex mandatario en
Florida
en otras noticias de Estados Unidos el
estado de Wyoming prohibió las píldoras
para abortar el gobernador republicano
Mark Gordon promulgó el viernes el
proyecto de ley que declara ilegal
recetar dispensar distribuir vender o
usar los medicamentos abortivos la norma
excluye los tratamientos que se
necesiten para proteger a las mujeres
cuya vida y salud estén en peligro
inminente pero para el resto de personas
que usan la píldora para abortar podrán
podrán estar hasta seis meses en la
cárcel y pagar multas de hasta 9000
dólares
El Vaticano anunció el cierre de su
embajada en Nicaragua a petición del
gobierno de Daniel Ortega luego de la
escalada diplomática entre ambos estados
que se extendió durante semanas tras la
medida el representante de la santa sede
monseñor Marcial de territorio
nicaragüense hacia Costa Rica
Nicaragua sin presencia del Vaticano la
santa sede mediante su página web
vatican news informó del cierre de la
embajada a petición del gobierno
nicaragüense además el viernes salió su
representante en el país monseñor diufa
Costa Rica el arzobispo de Managua y
cardenal Leopoldo brenes prefirió no
emitir un juicio Entonces yo no me
quiero meter en problemas porque son
cuestiones de derechos y son cuestiones
de estado de relaciones de estado
Entonces mejor cuando yo no no tengo
conocimiento profundo mejor guardo
silencio el gobierno de Daniel Ortega
anunció la semana pasada que se
planteaba una suspensión de relaciones
con la iglesia después de las palabras
del papa Francisco contra El Ejecutivo
fuera de lo que estamos viviendo es como
si fuera a traer
de dictaduras
de 17 comunistas o hitleriana del 35
están las águilas mismas
un tipo de dictaduras
groseras Esto fue En referencia al
obispo Rolando Álvarez condenado en
febrero a 26 años de prisión y quien
rechazó ser desterrado a Estados Unidos
con otros 222 opositores excarcelados
las relaciones con la iglesia no han
sido fáciles desde las protestas de 2018
el gobierno ha prohibido celebraciones
religiosas católicas en espacios
públicos por lo que el viernes el
viacrucis tuvo que celebrarse en los
alrededores de la Catedral
principalmente en este momento religioso
de que el gobierno sea más flexible que
deje que nuestras posesiones anden en
las calles y principalmente también que
nuestro querido monseñor Rolando Álvarez
esté con nosotros un enfrentamiento con
la que es la principal religión de
Nicaragua al menos 14 muertos dejó un
terremoto de magnitud 6,5 en Ecuador el
epicentro tuvo lugar en Guayaquil y
también se sintió en Perú la presidencia
ecuatoriana indicó en un comunicado que
más de 300 personas resultaron heridas y
descartó la advertencia de un posible
tsunami el presidente Guillermo lasso
dijo que su gobierno activó todos los
protocolos para atender a los
damnificados e iniciar la reconstrucción
de las viviendas que resultaron
afectadas
tenemos una fachada que se Aparentemente
colapso Y tenemos una víctima En eso
estamos ahorita en las operaciones o la
gente salía corriendo gritaba
desesperado toda la gente se bajaba de
los carros no sé cómo se sentirá un
sismo un carro pero era desesperada
corrían gritaban lloraban en Chile el
gobierno de Gabriel Boris vuelve a tener
sobre la mesa el tema de los indultos a
12 personas condenadas por sus acciones
durante el estallido social de 2019
salió la luz un informe de las
autoridades penitenciarias que habían
recomendado no otorgar estos beneficios
a seis de los 12 detenidos cabe recordar
que en su momento por este caso tuvo que
dimitirla entonces ministra de justicia
y el jefe de gabinete de Boris
una de las miembros del tribunal
internacional de los derechos de la
naturaleza demandan que se detenga el
proceso del tren maya en la Península de
Yucatán en el sureste de México la
deforestación de la selva contaminación
de agua y despojo y expropiación de
tierras es parte de lo que han
enfrentado comunidades mayas desde que
comenzaron las obras del proyecto
insignia del presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador
Nelly Lleva más de 30 años dedicada a la
apicultura y es la primera vez que las
abejas no están siendo productivas no
hay duda las colonias están sufriendo
los efectos de la deforestación
ocasionada por la construcción del tren
maya en la selva de la Península de
Yucatán en el sureste mexicano qué es lo
que observamos las abejas tienen una
situación de yo les digo que están
desnutridas no tienen el mismo nutriente
no tienen la misma fuerza no tienen la
misma
Vamos a decir que la energía para
reproducirse desde su inicio el tren
Maya ha enfrentado más de 25 amparos de
asociaciones y organismos del medio
ambiente que buscan la suspensión de la
obra uno de los tramos más polémicos es
el cinco ubicado entre Tulum y Playa del
Carmen en el Estado Sureño de Quintana
Roo porque atraviesa y amenaza largos
tramos de Selva virgen que han sido
deforestados sistemas de Cuevas que se
han derrumbado con las maquinarias y
flujos hídricos que han sido alterados
he visto
cenotesado que ya no existen
donde estamos ahora
está condenado está moribundo
va a morir no hemos fallado en salvarlo
la selva que quitaron de aquí la selva
que yo conocí que estaba arriba este
cenote ya no está pues es del tribunal
internacional de los derechos de la
naturaleza constataron las violaciones
al medio ambiente y notaron la
afectación a cientos de especies que
viven aquí la selva maya
como que agoniza como que
dice pide auxilio pide auxilio al mundo
a los ecologistas a la comunidad
científica que intervenga y a las Cortes
internacionales para decir que pare esto
el gobierno de México con este proyecto
insignia intenta construir 1.550
kilómetros de vía de ferrocarril a
través de cinco estados del sureste del
país y su meta es inaugurado en
diciembre de 2023 desde grandes
depredadores como el jaguar Hasta los
más pequeños como las abejas están
resintiendo el atropello del tren que
aún no pasa pero que ya deja sentir sus
efectos hasta que este informativo
Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]